right now the recovery right here in  clark county is almost 85 percent  and we asked the southern nevada health  district what criteria they use to come  up with that number here's what they  told us  it requires the person who tested  positive to  one be alive and not be  reported as death or have a death  certificate two to not  currently be hospitalized or in the last  seven days um have a discharge date and  then three  completed their quarantine or isolation  period  so she says there are some limitations  when it comes to daily reporting because  there are unknown factors  that could be if the patient still has  symptoms or if their hospital release  date has not yet been posted